[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to my 23rd episode of dirty
chess tricks against sicilian
in today's lecture we are going to see a
beautiful trick
in the richter rouser attack from the
white perspective
the opening arises after the following
move order
e4 c5 knight to f3
d6 d4 c captures d4
knight captures d4 knight to f6
knight to c3 and now black goes for the
classical sicilian setup
starting with knight to c6
okay the richter rouser attack commence
with
bishop to g5 trying to give black
a double pawn so accordingly
e6 is the main line and after that
white plays another forcing move bishop
to b5
attacking the c6 knight well black hand
is force
he has to defend on c6 so bishop to d7
and after that white continue his tricky
journey
with bishop captures knight
well black has two options and amongst
them
b capture c6 is the main line however
you should note that if your opponent
continue with
bishop capture c6 then our first trick
comes into the table immediately after
the following
sequence knight capture c6
pawn capture c6 and now this lovely pawn
sacrifice
e5 now as the black knight is spin
black responds his force he has to take
on e5
and after that queen to f3
[Laughter]
and suddenly black is in a huge trouble
well obviously white has a multiple
thread including
queen capture c6 and if black wind moves
somewhere
then bishop to f6
so to defend on c6 the natural move here
is
rook to see it bearing all the threat
but unfortunately this leads to
disaster first white
come up with a rook to d1 attacking the
queen
remember queen has to safeguard the f6
knight
so queen to e7 is the only reply
and after that the simplest move in the
world
castle on the king side
and it is easy to say that black is
completely losing his king side pieces
are completely stuck
and on top of everything white has a
simple thread
knight to e4 which more or less sealed
the victory
one game from the database finished very
quickly
black played at 6 but after bishop to h4
g5 and bishop to g3
now the e5 pawn become target and when
black defended with knight to d7
white has this winning shot knight to e4
which was way too strong that black has
to
resign the game
okay b capture c6 what else and here
my recommendation is you should start
with queen to f3
remain very flexible to castle
either side of the board and accordingly
white has some genuine replies such as
f6
and e5 but one move
which leads to disaster and in fact
as per the online database bishop to e7
has been played in more than 40 games
which i am afraid allow white
to execute his nasty trick
and the star move with sets up the
platform is
e5
here black has two options first
if we take on e5 then this is the worst
one
as after the simple knight capture c6
attacking on multiple location so black
hand is force
he has to remove this dangerous knight
but after queen capture c6 black cannot
interpose queen
as the rook in the corner hank if he
continue with
king to f8 then after castle
black get a sets of double pawn and a
horrible king placement
which is more than sufficient to give
wide ample advantage
so that is right out of the equation
and the natural move knight to d7
completely fails due to
again this simple transaction bishop
captures e7
king takes e7 and after that
yup you guessed it castle on the coin
side
well this position is so bad that even
with the base play
black cannot survive from this position
for example rook to c8 attacking the
queen
queen to d6 jack king to e8
and now simple plan knight to b5
white's oral aim is he wants to munch on
a7
and then come on c6 which believe it or
not
but very difficult to stop
after the best queen e7 white can simply
take on a7
and once the queen trade happened
if you see the net result the three
distant connected past pawn are more
than sufficient
to convert the full point
the second choice black is having here
is knight to d5
but again i am afraid this does not
solve the issue
as after bishop captures e7 queen
captures e7
white has a very strong reply queen to
g3
[Music]
and suddenly black to his horror
find out that he is going to lose
a vital pawn the point is
if let's say black continue with d
captures e5
then white has this in-between move
queen captures g7
attacking the rook and after rook to f8
and the move queen captures e5
suddenly white emerged with an extra
pawn
so that's not a right option
if knight captures c3 then we can simply
recapture with the b
pawn and the threat remain
as it is and finally
the best move in this position is castle
on the king side
but after this yup you guessed it
e captures d6 queen to f6
and the very simple move knight to b3
confirms that with the extra pawn
and some horrible pawn structure on the
queen side
white is clearly on the driving seat
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile trick in the richter rouser
attack
remember if you open and continue here
with bishop
to e7 then after white's wonderful
e5 no matter however black wriggles
it is only white who is coming out
on top in each of the line
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe
and comment and i will meet you in my
next episode
very soon bye and take care